[Music]
i have a story to recount
i hurt my ankle quite badly
there
done that's my story
wait did you really hurt your ankle i
did i rolled my ankle on some ice i was
walking on ice and i rolled it and uh it
was quite painful and it wouldn't get
better and so i finally went to uh cvs
and i don't know why but i went and got
one of those compression socks that
helps hold your foot together yeah i've
never felt older in my life than buying
a compression sock i bought a
compression sock i went first of all
when you when you walk through the aisle
and someone says can i help you sir and
you say
where are the compression socks
and they say oh right this way sir and i
could tell he even spoke more loudly i'm
like i'm not that old i think of myself
as a very young dynamic
you felt older getting compression socks
than you did the time you got orthotics
what okay i got orthotics
anyone can get children can get
orthotics okay you know and i got
orthotics
because i was having some low back pain
and it was suggested to me that uh maybe
i was pronating a little bit which was
causing uh some problems in my low back
so i got orthotics and the problem went
away but then you used to tease me
anytime i would say sona i've gotta
reorder some my orthotics
and you can't say i need to reorder my
orthotics without sounding like a
complete
doofus
and i would try different ways i'd be
like so anyway it's really important
that we uh reorder those orthotics and
every time you do it but compression
socks and orthotics those are things
that the minute you bring them up it's
over so i went and i got a compression
sock yeah and then i said i've got to
put this compression sock on my ankle
and the guy was like okay and i said but
first i'll need to remove my orthotics
and the guy was like uh okay whatever
you got to do and then i said by the way
i'm still a sexual threat
anyone what i'm still a sexual threat to
any women out there oh
once i get my uh compression socks over
my orthotics i'm ready to be a sexual
threat
to all the women out there
i've got big dick energy with my
orthotic
and my
compression sack this compression sock
is for my big dick it's such a threat
yeah
i sprained my penis
now my penis needs orthotics and a
compression sock
and it also needs an aloe gel
[Laughter]
hello why is this store emptying out
does anyone know i'm a section sexual
thread in aisle four
we've got a sexual threat in aisle four
oh anyway
if you see me limping down the street
ladies and gentlemen that's the story
that's the story
you